"yOUTUBE TOUGHENS ADVERT PAYMENT RULES"
*HEAVY BREATHING*
*le angry pewds*
oH
tHIS IS IT, YOUTUBE!
Now you've made me really mad!
I'm so angry
*SLAP*
I challenge you to BATTLE!
*Dragon Ball Super: YouTube Black Arc*
This announcement was trending on Twitter:
"#YouTubePartnerProgram"
Youtubers were tweeting about it having; different opinions about it
Controversial... but the problem here is that
They're all wrong. They're all wrong.
I am the only one that is correct
and if you don't know what I'm talking about,
let me just explain what that-- what is happening.
Basically, YouTube came out and said that
SURPRISE! if you don't have
4,000 hours of watch time AND a thousand subscribers
*devil voice* THEN YOU MEAN NOTHING TO US!
They-- They didn't exactly say that.
To be fair that's not what they said..
But basically that was it.
I like how they added at the end of the statement:
"One of YouTube's core values is to provide
anyone the opportunity to earn money from a thriving channel."
Well, now you're kind of saying one thing and doing the other.
You can't do that.
Now, my personal reaction to this, was--
the first instinct was: "Okay, so?"
"Logan Paul filmed a dead body?"
"And smaller channels have to suffer"
Uhhh... how does that make any sense?
It almost sounds a bit similar to the Adpocalypse, where
Youtube said that "Youtube would no longer allow
creators to make money until they reach 10,000 views."
Big creator messes up, small channels suffer.
I am so sorry about the adpocalypse, by the way, in case I haven't apologized, okay?
That was definitely me that put those advertisements
On those military, ISIS, racist videos, okay?
I'm sorry about that. I feel really bad about it. :c
Basically the reason why Youtube did this is because they said
Phrasing: "It's been clear over the last few months that we need the right requirements and better signals to identify channels that have
earned the right to run ads."
So basically, adding the bar to 10,000 views is not enough for YouTube to make sure that
ads don't appear on
Videos that they don't want it to. And ah, you know, I gotta give YouTube props for always, always
Anytime they announce anything it's always such a mess. No one really knows
what's going on and it leads people to be confused and angry and, uh
It's just the same thing every time. People are saying that so now
If i'm not in the partnership program  anymore, does that mean my videos aren't gonna get recommended? Because they're
Not earning revenue which each of us said
No, to before but it's, still kind of like, "Uhh.. Is that really true?" Everyone seemed to notice it differently.
People asking like, oh, okay, so now I'm not in the partnership program anymore.. uh
but what about promotion? And I can't schedule uploads, and losing all these benefits.
What is that gonna mean for me and why isn't that just a standard for anyone on Youtube, really.
And also, people who are not in the partnership program anymore is asking like
Hey, am I even gonna get paid? I know it's not a lot of money but am I gonna get it or not? like
probably you are, but the fact that these questions aren't answered it's always such a
mess and it's always so unnecessary. A plus for Youtube for always
Communicating so well. Usually, I find that Youtube isn't half as evil as it seems to be.
Doing these things, it's just they can't seem to communicate.
What it is they're actually doing. And then, All these- All these-
outrage comes in and-
Then they just pull back even more. Now-
we have youtubers, like, KEEMSTAR,  *roll the clip*
KEEM: So now everyone's asking me, well what advice you have for small youtubers?
KEEM: QUIT. You cannot make it in this game anymore. Alright? You're not going to make it.
KEEM: There is way too much competition.
Technically he's not wrong it's tough as hell to be a youtuber these days.
But the thing is, it's always been hard. Youtube, right now, really pushes for watch time. Unless you upload regularly.
And long videos you are gonna suffer. And I think this is the real issue here. This is what you should be pissed off about.
That put a lot effort and a-
Really good channels don't get as much exposure as they might deserve because-
They don't fit in this quota. And it's always been like this. Channels come and go on YouTube because they-
Maybe fit what the algorithm of YouTube wants and it's always there's been a wave of people coming-
and going.
And that may not deserve it or not because of this.
Youtube has never turned a profit.
EVER.
Since they they've done it. And I think they're really trying to change that. But if anything has shown-
That youtube is not a sustainable business model-
Atleast no one's done it right yet. And that's why there's no competition to YouTube just because it's so hard to figure out. Even If you have some-
Youtube being so extremely successful with its creator.
IT'S STILL NOT PROFIT. YouTube said, that he *they*, would maally-manually review all relevant content-
By the end of march. Because of this Logan Paul  thing. They said that they're-
Gonna have more than ten thousand workers reviewing clips by the end of 2018.
Uhh...
That's a lot of workers to review videos. Now here's my, my, main point with this is this tweet that i saw actually, yesterday.
"Hahaha, my sister used to upload littlest petshop videos on youtube when she was nine and she accidentally enabled ad?
revenue, which checked her adsense account
Yesterday and she made 1,500 bucks turn up like that's, awesome i'm not, gonna hit on that i don't really have an
Issue with it this is what you took trying to prevent with this there's only so many ads on youtube?
It's not an infinite amount. You may be watching my channel sometimes and there's no, ads on it and uh,
That might be because there was not enough, ads to go around it happens all the time that you watch a video
Ads might be enabled but they don't show
Up, because there's not enough to go around and i personally think that stopping channels that are
Coming out of nowhere just to upload other people's contents, like movies and tv shows
And that stuff cutting, off those people from making revenue and taking, away
Ads from channels that are actually
Dedicated and uploading videos it makes sense to me a lot of people get really pissed because of the
4,000 hours thing and i understand that that's frustrating but.
People, did the math and essentially it comes down to like four dollars four bucks
A month or something like and if you arguing, about that amount then, maybe you should, ask, yourself, why are you
Making youtube videos it's always been hard to be a small channel always
Back in the day, youtube used to have a, manual partnership program
Where you'd have to apply and hopefully make it in and i trust me you needed more than a thousand subscribers to get into that
If anything it's clearly been too easy to put ads on your channel and for bucks that doesn't seem like
You're, looking at the bigger picture you're complaining, about that personally i didn't make, any revenue of youtube after making videos for a
Whole year even more i think i had like twenty five thousand subscribers and youtube wouldn't touch my, channel they
wouldn't partner it and it was extremely frustrating because i
felt like i had i had the chance to finally push in and make it into a living but i
Couldn't but it was way beyond four dollars?
I understand that it's tough as hell to get to a thousand subscribers and i remember that seemed singing possible
But if you're looking at it as a way to you should earn revenue before that so you can get a
Few dollars that doesn't to me doesn't really, justify the the end goal that they're trying to
Do here blocking out people from uploading
Bad content to youtube or perhaps creating another, media system the only way i could earn, revenue back in the day
Was to sign up with a network youtube wouldn't touch gaming channels and i only?
Did gaming channel back then and so many youtubers not just, me but just got royally screwed over by networks
Taking, what like half of their revenue and giving, what back people don't talk, about that but four dollars
Oh, no like, yes it's it's hard as hell to be a small channel i know that but it sure as, hell
Wasn't easier, back in the day i think it's great that youtube is partnering
Channels now and this is what they have to do to make it happen
And it seems just fair to me even though it might seem hard it's good a lot of people saying
Well it's motivating maybe getting a little bit of revenue and seeing that you are earning something i agree but
The ends doesn't justify the
Means and at the end of the day i think it's sort of a healthy approach that maybe you shouldn't be earning
Revenue the very first thing
Maybe that should be a goal
maybe you should be incentivized to work on your subscribers and
building an audience first instead of earning revenue first i
Understand that there's more things to it but to me
Youtube is like a runner the fastest runner alive and then someone just tied his shoes together and he fell and now he's retarded
I stole that joke from brad but it's, so true since there's no competition to youtube i think it's very important that when
Bad things happen or when they, do bad things that we do?
Stand up against them i think it's important that, we are united as a community but i also feel like
This is not that big a, deal
Save your energy, and save your outrage for something more important that will have a bigger
Effect on the platform and I hope that smaller channels don't get discouraged by this.
Keep working hard, I know it sucks,
it's always sucked. Uh, I do see new
channels try and it and it isn't impossible anyway i've been going on for too long
and that's just my thought about it. What do you think -  is YouTube screwing over its creators?
Here's a poll (pole it's a joke thanks pewds)
And that's it for me for now, goodbye